مساء الخير الازمه في الجزائر اي ازمه
اخرى في العالم فيها جوهر وفيها تفاصيل
التفاصيل يعني اسماء الشخصيات والاحداث
والمطالب والمطالب المضاده هذه التفاصيل
مربكه لكن جوهر الازمه بسيط وواضح احنا
قدام
نظام متمسك بالسلطه حتى اخر نفس وامام
شارع محبط محبط وغاضب ورافض للاوضاع
الحاليه ومصدر احباط والحقيقه عاملين
اساسيين اداء اقتصادي شيء على الاقل سيء
بالنسبه لدوله المفروض على الورق انها بلد
غني والامر الثاني حاله من التكلف
والستين او الانسداد السياسي منذ سنوات
طويله جدا نفس السياسات نفس النتائج نفس
الوجوه منذ العام الف وتسع مائه اثنين
وستين والى الاهلي اذا حبينا ناخذ فكره
كده عن الاداء الاقتصادي الجزائر
وكان فيه وكميه زمان بتقول اغنيه امريكا
كده بتقول والافراج ما فيه يعني حين
يفسد الحب فلا شيء ابدا يمكن ان نصلح شيء
كلمه الحق حق كلمه الاقتصاد
طالما الاقتصاد مشبعا فيه ممكن تتوقع كل
انواع الاضطرابات السياسيه تعلن شوف
الاقتصاد الجزائري بيقول ايه احنا المفروض
على الورق ان الجزائر البلد فنيه لان هي
واحده من القوى الكبرى في العالم في مجال
الطاقه ربنا اعطائها ثروات ضخمه جدا سواء
بترول او غاز احنا بنتكلم على الجزائر
اللي هي رقم سطاشر على العالم من حيث
الاحتياطات المؤكده من البترول عندها
احتياطات اكثر من اطناشر مليار برميل بطول
وهي رقم سته على العالم من حيث الاحتياطات
المؤكده في الغاز الطبيعي ورقم 3
في الغاز الصخري اللي عندها منه كميات
وفيره المفروض انه ينعكس على الداخلي
انعكس على الاداء
ينعكس على مستوى معيشه الناس ان ام واقع
الامر نحنا قدام بلد الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي
الجديد الجزائر بتكلم في حدود مائه وسبعين
مليار دولار
بدي اتكلم على نصيب الفرد من هذه
الثروه بتتكلم على حوالي اربعه الاف مائه
ثلاثه وثلاثين اه اه اربعه الاف دولار
يعني اربعه ثلاثمائه وثلاثه وثلاثين دولار
في السنه دامت اسمه طبعا الرقم
لكن الجزائر سياسه يكون لدول العالم
الثروه تتكدس في ادين مجموعه قليله جدا من
الناس بنلاقي نسبه البطاله متوسطها متوسط
هامش اخر رقم على مدار ثمنطاشر سنه
الماضيه في حدود 14 دكتور يعني ما بين كل
بيئه الجزائري في اكثر من اربعطاشر شخص
معطل عن العمل
ونسبه البطاله بين فئات الشباب لتصل
تقريبا الى ثلاثين في المائه والبطاله
يعني كل امراض الدنيا بقه ومؤشر على فشل
الحكومه في اطاره الاقتصاد لان البطاله
يعني ما فيش وظيفه يعني فيه فقر يعني في
احباط يعني في كل شيء سيء التقارير
الدوليه بتقول معلومه مهمه الجزائر مش بس
ان الاداء الاقتصادي
على ما يرام ولكن كمان ان الجزائر بلد غير
مرحب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وهو بلد مغلق
مؤشرات يعني حقيقتين ممكن يوضح لنا الوضع
رقم واحد حجم الاستثمارات الاجنبيه
المباشره في الجزائر هي متوسطه على مدار
السنين اللي فاتت الاخر عشره خمسطاشر سنه
في حدود ستمائه مليون دولار فقط في
الجزائر ومعظمها تتركز في قطاع النفط لو
تكلمنا مثال اخر يوضح لنا سوق المال او
البورصه من اقل المستويات او من اقل
البورصات اداء على مستوى العالم وليس
المنطقه لانه الحقيقه ما فيش يعني اهتمام
كثير اوي بمساله الاستثمارات الاجنبيه
وبالتالي ما فيش اهتمام ب سوق المال وده
مؤشر على عدم اهتمام السلطات الجزائريه
بفكره الاستثمار الاجنبي ودخول
الاستثمارات جديد عندي ارقام كثيره بس
الوقت لكن اقول لكم اللي انا قلت مثال على
وضع الجزائر ولا ناس كثيره محبطه من
الاداء ال ال ال ال الاقتصاديه المتواضع
اللي بيزيد لما اسعار البترول بضربه و
اسعار البترول لو لاحظنا انه انتفاضات
الجزائريين مرتبطه بشكل بشكل غير مباشر
باسعار البطوله ولو تفتكروا انه في سنه
ثمانيه وثمانين وتسعه وثمانين والجزائريين
ذلك جيدا ان في انتفاضات انتفاضه كبيره
الانتفاضه بدات اقتصاديه ثم تحولت الى
مطالب سياسيه ايضا وكان احتجاجا على
الاسعار وقتها كان السبب الاساسي انه
اسعار البترول انخفضت بشكل كبير اصبحت
قدره الحكومه اللي تعتمد بشكل كبير جدا
على مدخلات ها من النفط توفير مطالب الناس
تقرر المساله في الانتخابات الاخيره في ال
ال الاحتجاجات الاخيره اللي جزء منها في
خلفيته بدا احتجاجا على الاسعار وعلى
البطاله ايضا لانه فيه مشاكل في اسعار
البترول المضطربه والماء له للانخفاض من
2014 والى الامن على مستوى الاقتصاد وعلى
مستوى السياسه
اللي اثنين السلطه والشعب هو الشارع
المشتركين في شيء واحد ان كلاهما عاجزه عن
ايجاد بديل للرئيس عبد العزيز بوتفليقه
ربنا مشى عليه بالشفاء
الشارع عاجزه عن ايجاد بديل واضح لانه هو
محتاج غاضب رافض فقط لكن معندوش القدره او
لم ينجح في انه يقدم لنا شخصيه يطرح
باعتبرها مرشح المعارضه الى الرئيس
بوتفليقه
والسلطه رغم انه هي موجوده في السلطه
النظام يعني في السلطه بشكل متصل في نفس
الاداره اداره الرئيس عبد العزيز بوتفليقه
وفي نفس الحزب اللي بيحكم الجزائر من سنه
اثنين وستين ومع ذلك هو عاجز التفسير في
تقديري يعني انه احنا قدام رئيس غاب عن
السلطه غير عن متابعه ال الشؤون اليوميه
وبالتالي ترك الامور بحكم حالته الصحيه
اصبح هناك فيه صراع اجنحه ومع الصراع
الاجنحه اصبح
الاجنحه المختلفه اذا كانت
الحزب اذا كانت الجيش اذا كانت الاجهزه
الامنيه اذا كانت رجال الاعمال اذا كان
عدد من افراد اسره الرئيس كله يتصارع على
التامين مصلحه وبالتالي مش قادرين يستقروا
على شخصيه واحده تحمي مصالحهم المعارضه
احيانا والمتشابكه احيانا وفي نفس الوقت
تكون مقبوله من امور الشعب يخلف الرئيس
عبد العزيز بوتفليقه وكل ما كان له ربما
يدور العافيه حين كان لائقا بكل ما كان له
من قلق
الوضع الان
احنا في الوضع دلوقتي عندنا شارع لمطالب
وحكومه لها تصور للاستجابه للمطالب مطالب
الشارع انه انه انه يخرج الرئيس عبد
العزيز بوتفليقه
وقد خرج من السباق الانتخابي لكن يخرج من
السباق الانتخابي ويخرج من الحياه
السياسيه ويكفي ما قدم مشكورا وانه
الانتخابات تقام
مباشره وتنافس فيها الجميع ما عدا الرئيس
عبد العزيز بوتفليقه
ولم اطلبوا التعديل طلبوا التاهيل لفتره
بسيطه بحيث ان يسمح لمن انسحبوا اعتراضا
على دخول الرئيس بوتفليقه بالعوده الى
سباق الانتخابات
وتعقد الانتخابات خلال اسبوع شهرين على
الاكثر لكن الحكومه على ان الرئيس قدمت
مجموعه اخرى من ال
المقترحات اللي ب يعكس ايضا رغبه السلطه
في البقاء في السلطه يعني النظام يبقى في
السلطه الى ما شاء الله ايه هي التصور
اللي معرضه كلكم عارفين انه الرئيس لن
يترشح لولايه 5
وابن سوف يظل في السلطه فقط حتى يجري
حوارا وطنيا تحت اشرافه ثم تعديلات
دستوريه ثم انتخابات رئاسيه ما يعني بين
قوسين ان الشعب اعترض على ولايه خامسه
فكان اقتراح السلطه الم بلاش ولايه خمسه
وخلونا في ولايه رابعه مفتوحه لانه لم
يحدد اي مده زمنيه للاجراءات الثلاثه
وبالتالي قوبلت
المقترحه بالرفض دلوقتي احنا قدمنا مجموعه
من السيناريوهات وانا انقل هنا هذه
السيناريوهات
عن الدكتور اسعد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
المرموقه اللي درست الحاله الجزائريه بعمق
واستفاد وهي شايفه من ايراداتها انه
السيناريوهات في الغالب لم تخرج عن الاتي
ان الشعب يستطيع ان يضغط على الحكومه
ويلزمها بان هي تستجيب لمطالب وتجري
انتخابات في خلال فتره قصيره جدا بعد
انسحاب الرئيس
والله الانتخابات فقد تؤدي تؤكد لحين عوده
من انسحبوا الى سباق الانتخابات
او انه الحكومه تقنع الشارع
بنفس سيكون
اللي هو حوار وطني تعديلات دستوريه ثم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه على ان ترضى الشارع
بتحديد فتره زمنيه مقبوله تطمئن الناس انه
المساله لن تكون مفتوحه الى الامام
السيناريو الثالث انه ممكن او اللي هو
القريب من السيناريو الثاني انه يتفقوا
على انشاء مثل السياسي في مجلس اعلى
الدوله على غرار المجلس الذي انشاته
الجزائر في سنه اثنين وتسعين عقب وقف
المسار الانتخابي اللي كانت متقدم في جبهه
الانقاذ الاسلاميه والرئاسه محمد بوضياف
قبل اغتياله في وقت اللائحه عده شهور على
ان يضم هذا المجلس من الاطراف من النظام
واطراف من المعارضه واطراف من الشباب
ويكون ممثل ل اطياف مختلفه ويكون مهمه هذا
المجلس هو اداره الفتره الانتقاليه واعداد
البلاد الى انتخابات رئاسيه قادمه السلام
الرابع والاخير وهو الاسوء ونتمنى لا قدر
الله الا تدل ف اليه الجزائر هو ان كل طرف
سيتمسك
بمطالبه لاخر لحظه ونصل الى مرحله الصدام
وتزيد
الاحتجاجات وتتحول الى احتجاجات عنيفه
وتهديد وتزيد ال ال المظاهرات وتتحول الى
عصيان مدني ثم
تصبح البلاد تدخل الى مرحله فوضى واضطر
الجيش ان يدخل كما دخل في التسعينات الى
الشارع ونبه قدام سيناريوهات لا قدر الله
في اسواقها في افضلها
حقق من السيناريو هديه هذا مرهون بمدى
رشاد كل الافراد في تحكيم العقل وانه
يعلوا المصلحه العامه ونوصل بحكمه الى
سيناريو مقبول يعني يرضى كل الاطراف او
على الاقل او ال او الاصح يرضى كل القوى
اللي موجوده المؤكد شيء واحد فقط وهو ان
قطار التغيير قد انطلق وان الجزائر التي
عرفناها
العام الف وتسع مائه اثنين وستين وحتى هذه
اللحظه لن تعود ابدا كما كانت لكن الى اين
يتجه قطر التغيير هذا هو السؤال نسال الله
للشعب الجزائري الاشقاء في الجزائر كل خير
وكل السلام وان يكونوا في الحاضر
والمستقبل افضل بكثير مما كانوا في الماضي
والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]